what's up everybody its Warren and we
have some absolutely incredible news
today not too long ago it was reported
that a Hulk verse will Vereen video was
in the works at marvel studios and today
based off of what Mark Ruffalo the Hulk
himself has said in a recent interview
it seems like this may have been proven
true also if you enjoy true inside
scoops for Marvel be sure to follow
Daniel RPK on YouTube he does a lot for
the community and leaks a lot so I'll
link him down below be sure to give him
a follow mark ruffalo has officially
hinted that this could in fact be coming
to the MCU recently while he was at
Tokyo's Comic Con it also seems like
Mark Ruffalo has indeed confirmed that
he's not done playing The Hulk so let's
go ahead and break down this new report
I'm still doing my Xbox one and ps4
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be subscribed with notifications turned
on like this video and leave a comment
down below so at Tokyo Comic Con Mark
Ruffalo stated that he has recently met
with Kevin Feige and talked about the
Hulk in the MCU he revealed that he was
talking to the president of Marvel
Studios Kevin Feige
about the future of the Hulk in the MCU
and this is reportedly only last week
when this happened a Tokyo comic-con he
said Kevin Feige just asked me last week
if I had any more ideas or stories for
the Hulk and I said yeah I think there's
still some stories to tell and he said
well why don't you come in and tell me
about them and we'll see if we can find
a place for you in the Marvel Universe
and as it turns out one of those ideas
that Mark Ruffalo has for the Hulk
involves a certain mutant Wolverine Mark
Ruffalo went on to say Hulk vs.
Wolverine I'd like to see that Hulk vs.
Wolverine so we heard it directly from
Mark Ruffalo himself he stated that he
has already met with Marvel Studios
President Kevin Feige just last week to
talk about the future of the Hulk in the
MCU which is where he most likely
pitched the idea of Hulk vs. Wolverine
and if that has not already happened we
have confirmation from Mark Ruffalo
himself that he will be meeting with
Kevin Feige soon as you heard before
Kevin Feige told him why don't you come
in and tell me about your idea so we can
find a place for you in the Marvel
Universe and as Mark Ruffalo said he
would like to see the Hulk vs. Wolverine
and as many of you know
is now possible Disney now owns the
rights to use the x-men in the MCU and a
lot of people thought that the Hulk was
really done dirty in Avengers infinity
war and Avengers endgame but what better
way is there for the Hulk to redeem
himself than to go up against Wolverine
himself and honestly what better way to
introduce Wolverine into the MCU than to
have him go up against the Hulk fans
have been wanting this for a very long
time and now it seems like Mark Ruffalo
wants this as well now there always is
the possibility that this has already
been talked about and Mark Ruffalo was
just kind of playing aloof there were
reports several months ago about a Hulk
vs. Wolverine movie in development at
Marvel Studios and not to mention not
too long ago only several months ago
Kevin Feige did a Q&A on reddit and in
this Q&A somebody asked him about the
future of the Hulk in the MCU and he
replied that him and Mark Ruffalo have
recently sat down and talked about the
future of the Hulk and he said that Mark
Ruffalo felt like his story was not done
and that he pitched a lot of new ideas
for the Hulk and keep in mind this was a
long time ago several months ago so it's
possible that Kevin Feige and Mark
Ruffalo have already had this talk about
Hulk vs. Wolverine but Mark Ruffalo is
just now mentioning it and we know that
Kevin Feige is excited to introduce
these new characters to the MCU he has
said it many many times he once said
that there are hundreds of names on
those documents on those agreements and
the fact that Marvel is as close as we
may ever get now to having access to all
of the characters is something I've been
dreaming about for almost 20 years at
Marvel and it's very exciting
so it appears like a Hulk vs. Wolverine
movie is very very possible for the MCU
confirmed by Mark Ruffalo himself it
seems like him in Marvel Studios
President Kevin Feige are going to be
talking about this very very soon if
they haven't already so I know everybody
is just super excited so let me know
what you think about this in the
comments down below like the video if
you enjoyed this news and don't forget
to subscribe with notifications turned
on to stay up to date on everything
relating to the MCU and if you'd like a
chance to win an Infinity Gauntlet click
the link down below as always thank you
all so much for watching
woof woof